what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 13 of 3d game
programming in Java okay
it is it is time to do some render
distance limiting and why we're doing
that is because well most people said
that to render distance so that's what
we're going to do I'm not going to keep
showing you guys everything I'm sure you
believe me and you go check it out
yourself
but anyway point is what doing render
distance and it's something that I've
sort of wanted to do for a while so yeah
let's get right into this so first of
all um we had this problem last time
we're just simply would not run properly
and that that is nothing to do with the
code that is as Clips clearly tells us I
don't know why didn't realize this last
time it says as a breakpoint at line 42
and basically what a breakpoint is is
it's a place it's like a an indicator
that you set in the actual IDE in
Eclipse
where you want the code to break so that
you can diagnose it further in some
circumstances so as you can see there's
like a little a what is that like a blue
orb looks like a sphere like a circle
with a nice gradient to it double click
if you don't know if you get this from a
probably won't but double click and it's
gone and now it will run fine don't know
why I didn't realize that last time I
was tired as I said but yeah you can
double it you can click it anywhere you
want and it's simply not going to work
as you can see what will work eventually
again if we just click this like three
times or not at all anyway point is we
fixed that last value fix fit that is
fixed okay let's get right on into the
surrounded distance limiting thing so I
want to sort of talk about it a bit I
today as well I'm just going to open up
a render 3d cloth since this is
basically what it is oh where where our
3d stuff is so if you look at this right
now and let's just put it like that and
if you look at the FPS we're getting
about 100 you know it's not too bad I
usually get about 120
it's probably just 100 because I'm
strong record and but the the main
purpose really removing this is it's to
be honest it's sort of aesthetical
because removing this is
gonna increase FPS by that much probably
by about 20 maximum and the thing that's
going to happen is we're going to need
to sort of smooth it out and to do that
that's actually going to bring our FPS
down and we're going to talk about two
ways of doing this and these are like
the two ways that they're armed that I
know how to do it that I've just sort of
come up with pretty much on the spot so
yeah let's go let's get right on into
this okay so the thing that controls and
like all of this I really want you guys
to understand that all this is purely
logical and why is it telling me I'm not
connected to the Internet
I'm gonna clearly AM Windows 7 what are
you doing that's really weird
anyway that's annoying me anyway um so
yeah so let's let's think about this
from a from a logical point of view what
controls ours again what controls our
Zed at the moment and it's kind of this
control Z but anyway what controls our
depth and the variable controls our
depth is actually the variable called
called Z which is right here okay so
what we need to do think about this is
we're going to go ahead and say that
okay well if if Z is basically above a
certain distance that we want to render
just don't render anything beyond that
distance is what we're saying so let's
take a look at this from a from this
point of view let's write a quick if
statement and I'm actually going to sort
of play around with this a bit so if
let's do it for our X let's let's take a
look at our horizontal stuffs okay okay
so if X say is above I don't know 50
then set pixels pixels X plus y times
width so there's the same pixels that we
using to actually render as you can see
just set them to 0
you know first let's check that out okay
so you can see that basically else sort
of Universal inverses
okay so yeah you can sort of see how
that's working yeah so basically yeah
this is this pretty simple how this is
working we can inverse it as well and
we'll get the opposite but basically
what it's doing is they're saying if X
is above 50 so this is 50 pixels right
here then just set pixels equal to zero
you can see how framerate is sort of
gone up not too much so we'll talk about
it in a minute um but and of course the
game still works and stuff so that's X
and again you know if we set this to 100
then it's going to draw 100 pixels so
basically it's saying only render the
area that is 100 pixels or below because
if X exceeds 100 then just stop
rendering and we can do the same thing
with Y and that'll just do the top to
bottom thing again we can inverse this
and then finally let's talk about Z
change it to Z and look at that okay I
look around and look at that we've got
Reina distance limitation right there
now you can see that our frame rate has
gone up to about 120 115 115 to 120
average and without this statement if
you watch the frame rate counter right
here it's it on about 102 so we've
that's a marginal increase in
performance and that's sort of like a
really easy way to do this now we're
going to move on to the second part of
this of this tutorial and that is
actually smoothing it out now I thought
about this for a while and I think that
the weight like this is probably isn't
the best way this is just the way I'm
doing it um all of you guys who have
experience in in Java dinner and know a
better way to do this please like send
me a message or leave a comment below or
something because I'm they'll be greatly
appreciated because uh I'm I don't think
this is the best way to do it obviously
and the reason is that I okay so this is
quite quite ugly right because it's just
drawing like a black thing here and I'm
not trying to be racist here god that
sounded horrible
I'm not going to repeat that anyway
basically what it's doing is it's not
rendering anything past 100 we can sort
of increase out as well and it's sort of
kind of looks a bit ugly because it's
just it's just like it's just
immediately stopping there's no like
gradient so the way we can add a
gradient is I'm actually going to exit
out of this um okay let's check out how
we're going to add a gradient okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
come to the very end I think that's yep
we're going to get out of this method
now we're going to make another method
and I'm just going to call it R and a
distance limiter and you know standard
math equation thing and basically all
it's going to be is like a full loop and
int I equals 0 I is less than width
times height and actually what we need
to do right now is create a let's create
a um a quick double here public mm sort
of call it and it'll be an array Z
buffer and basically what is going to be
is it's going to be an array that will
take on our depth and you'll see that in
a minute and we need to go ahead and say
said buffer yeah said buffer equals new
hang on let me just get rid of this
equals new double width times height
right and yeah so and when it actually
come in here of course and set Z buffer
width times height to be equal to our Z
value so it's basically creating an
array out of this out of this Z this
depth value and yeah so that we can use
it as an array which is quite important
it's called a zero focus that's already
taken in buffers you know the branded
stuff said randa actually probably would
have been another word
anyway let's move on okay so go ahead
and create an integer we're going to
call it color and I'm going to spell it
the Australian way with with the you
that's the American Way and we're just
gonna have it equal two pixels and when
I set the array equal to i right there
and we're also going to make an integer
for the brightness and this will I'll
explain this in a minute but we sort of
want the Brighton's to fade off right
and I was going to have go ahead and
type render distance and we're going to
divide that by Z buffer I and we'll
actually put this in brackets as well
okay so let's go ahead and create a
render distance um a render distance
thing and we'll set that equal to I
don't know 1000 will check it out later
and that will sort of enable us to fade
off what's going on here
are we missing yeah we are we're missing
a curly bracket I got a normal bracket
okay so let's go ahead and say that if
and remember that in in programming arm
in graphics programming that the
brightness level ranges from 0 to 255
okay if you're any if you're in n into
any kind of graphics work even like
stuff like paint honestly then you know
you'll know the RGB values and you'll
know that brightness as well and the RGB
ranges from 0 to 255 so basically what
we need to say is if if our brightness
for some reason wants to go lower than 0
right so if it's less than 0 then well
that's not permitted
so let's just set it equal to 0 which
means that the minimum we're basically
basically what this if statement is
saying is that the minimum brightness
the minimum value that the integer
brightness can get in heret is 0 so it
cannot be lower than 0 and similarly we
need to do the same thing for the
maximum value so in other words if it
tries to go above 255 then set it equal
to 255 so if it tries to go above it set
it to 255 therefore setting the maximum
brightness value to 255 and we also need
to create a few integers for the I J and
B so and our G B and we'll go ahead and
fill this out real quick and this is
simply be our color shifted right 610
and this is just standard sort of Java
color stuff again that's that's a color
as you know that's like the beginning of
a color that's like that that's like the
hex I think it's called and 8 this time
and that's the green value and
FF and for the B it's basically just
without anything so color and 0ff okay
and we also need to set all these equal
to something so we've sort of
reinitiated them now we're going to go
ahead and say that the R value is going
to equal R times
brightness divided by 255 and the same
thing we're going to do for the G and
the B so um be G sorry is going to equal
the same basically the same thing I
should probably just copy and paste this
but you know obviously G times that we
could have done this in one line but I
think it looks better like this to be
honest to be honest with you okay that
looks good and finally we have course
data set our pixels equal to this these
sort of values that we've created here
so yep so that's sort of setting the ah
this is setting the be the G sorry and
this is setting the B and that's it so
that's basically our code for our render
distance limiter all we have to do okay
officer that's not going to run because
we're not we're not sort of calling that
method at the moment um so yeah so what
we need to do here is oh I'm sorry I
wonder it's ham we'll just fix this
error real quick it should be X plus y
times width
that'll at least run keep dragging it
onto my other monitor because that's the
way I roll when I program my code on a
live code
okay so let's um go into our screen
class here it is and simply just render
the render distance limiter and that
worked because our frame rate went down
and you can sort of see something
actually so yeah that worked okay let's
go ahead and go back to our when it is
delivered and set this render distance
equal to know something like 5,000 that
seem to have zero effect better restart
of some reason okay so yeah you consider
that worked and we get like a really
nice fading in the distance and we can
probably just remove this now because we
don't need it and yeah so that's I'm
just going to keep it here for fun
I might just set that equal to like 500
but um yeah so you can see that how that
sort of worked looking good
so yeah the major issue right now is
that it's actually gone down the
framerate and this is that's because
we're obviously using all this stuff so
honestly guys if you have any beer if
you have any better ideas then I don't
know leave comments send me a message
whatever you want to do and and we'll
look into them and I might include that
in the next episode okay so next up next
week I'm just probably going to just go
ahead and say that okay we're going to
do jumping all mouse movement so go
ahead and go to you know go to the
standard channel post a post response
here to say episode 14 as to what we you
want me to do and also two other things
really quick I've I've actually been
live streaming some battlefield 3
actually live stream this morning and I
probably going to do it in a few hours
as well after this video goes up so go
ahead and check out my live stream I
usually post a video when I'm
live-streaming or like a or a bulletin
or something to know exactly when a live
stream follow me on Twitter and for all
of you guys who are complaining that I'm
not answering your questions that's
actually cuz I get quite a bit quite a
lot of questions but if you head over to
my live stream when I'm live-streaming
and just asked me a question there on
the spot then I'm probably going to
answer it because you know it's live and
the other thing is I also have a
Facebook page the link is going to be on
the screen right now as well and in the
description so follow me on like me on
Facebook because if you if you sort of
want one out want to ask me a question
and you don't want to send me an email
or something if it's like a quick
question or whatever
then arm you know it's not limited to
140 characters like it is on Twitter so
yeah that's that's pretty awesome and
yeah that's about it and thanks for
watching and if you enjoyed this hit the
like button and I'm sorry yeah this is
probably going to slow down you think
quite a bit we might refine this quite a
bit later on and if anyone has any had
any ideas like I said earlier I want to
know them so yeah I'll see you guys
later bye
you